Traveling off the beaten tracks may not be super comfortable and organized,...
...but it also has its advantages.
The small and quiet fishing town of Kodungalloor in the Thrissur District of Kerala in India...
...was once a major port for thousands of years.
Apparently, Judaism, Islam and Christianity all came to India...
...through this port and have left their marks here.
The fascinating temple complexes downtown are worth seeing,...
...especially during the Bharani Festival in late March...
...where the goddess Kannagi is worshipped with songs and chicken sacrifices.
But outside the festival...
...there is also something going on like explosive sounds from the temple square,...
...hijras parading with swords, and older women cutting their forehead...
...to let the blood drip on the altar.
You can also arrange canoe trips into the backwaters with locals.
The best time to visit Kerala is between November and January...
...because it is relatively cool and dry.